somebody said do what you love and
you'll never work another day in your
life and that person was wrong do what
you love and you'll never work another
who the heck said that man like I do
enjoy getting up hustling I enjoy
leadership I enjoy working with our team
but like you're mistaken if you think
there's not days in YouTube and
Entrepreneurship where you're gonna wake
up your back freaking hurts and you're
tired and you don't feel like doing it
oh it's starting to feel like work maybe
I should stop what the heck are people
on man it's time to freaking get that
grit again whatever happened to that old
school salt of the earth time to put
some hustle in I'm gonna do it when I
feel like it and I'm gonna do it when I
don't feel like it I want to follow in
Sean's footsteps who created a
profitable passive income business and
now can do whatever I want whenever I
want wherever I want with whomever I
want now but you didn't see me when I'm
waiting tables and editing video and
working at a church and I didn't love
every minute of it I had a vision for
something bigger